bienvenido al vídeo de simplificación de
radicales seguramente te estás
preguntando ahorita que qué demonios es
eso de un radical entonces déjame
dibujar tf1
ahí está ese es un radical aunque
también es conocido como el símbolo de
la raíz cuadrada entonces cuando las
personas hablan de simplificación de
radicales en realidad están hablando de
simplificación de raíces cuadradas
entonces déjame borrar esto
para que veamos unos ejemplos y digamos
que queremos encontrar la raíz cuadrada
de 36 pues es esta muy fácil y no porque
36 es un cuadrado perfecto de hecho es 6
x 6
entonces si buscamos un número que
elevado al cuadrado nos dé 6 al cuadrado
pues ya lo tenemos no es tal cual 6
porque 6 al cuadrado es 6 por 6 que es
justo lo que tenemos adentro del radical
y el radical lo que busca es que número
si lo elevamos al cuadrado nos queda lo
de adentro bueno entonces vamos con otro
ejemplo digamos que queremos encontrar
la raíz cuadrada de 72 pues 72 lo
podemos escribir como
36 por 2 y entonces por propiedades de
los radicales esto es igual a la raíz de
36 por la raíz de 2 y la raíz de 36
acabamos de ver que es igual a 6
entonces esto es igual a 6 por la raíz
de 2 ahora este paso de aquí seguro se
siente como el paso de la muerte
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
recordar porque si estamos multiplicando
los números y le sacamos la raíz lo que
nos queda es la multiplicación de las
raíces de los dos números ok
resulta que si tenemos un número y le
estamos sacando la raíz cuadrada
esto es igual a tomar el número a y
elevarlo a la potencia un medio aunque
como sabemos esto pues porque la raíz de
a es un número al que le estamos
llamando b tal que
que si tomamos de y lo elevamos al
cuadrado nos queda a ok esta es la
definición de raíz de a aunque hay un
número que le estamos llamando b tal que
si lo elevamos al cuadrado nos queda a
entonces y tomamos esta b al cuadrado
que es igual a a y los elevamos a la
potencia un medio que lo elevamos a la
potencia un medio por las propiedades de
los exponentes que vamos a volver a
repasar en algunos vídeos esto es igual
a b elevado a la potencia 2 por un medio
2 por un medio pero 2 por un medio es
igual a 1 y b a la 1 es simplemente b
entonces podemos concluir que
a la 1 medio es igual a b que habíamos
dicho que es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de a ok entonces
siempre que tengamos una raíz cuadrada
podemos pensar que tenemos el número de
adentro o sea
elevado a la potencia un medio ok
bien ahora ya que sabemos esto podemos
deducir muy fácilmente esta propiedad
porque aquí lo que tenemos entonces es
36 por 2 elevado a la potencia un medio
y por propiedades de los exponentes eso
siempre es igual a 36 elevado a la un
medio x
2 elevado a un medio ok
estas propiedades de los exponentes las
vamos a volver a repasar nada más buscan
los vídeos que dicen propiedades de los
exponentes y ahí lo volvemos a explicar
con mucho detalle pero mientras tanto
esta es la razón por la cual podemos
dividir la raíz cuadrada de esta forma
aunque entonces la raíz de 72 la podemos
simplificar como 6 por la raíz de 2 y
esta raíz de 2 ya no la podemos
simplificar más entonces le vamos a
dejar tal cual
entonces vamos a borrar todo para ver
más ejemplos entonces ahora vamos a
sacar la raíz cuadrada de 50 bueno 50 lo
podemos escribir como 25 por 2 entonces
queremos la raíz cuadrada de 25 por 2 y
eso como acabamos de ver es igual a 25
por 2 elevado a la un medio y por
propiedades de los exponentes eso es
igual a 25 elevado a la un medio por 2
elevado a un medio que a su vez es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de 25 por la raíz
cuadrada de 2 aunque hay pero cuál es la
raíz cuadrada de 25 pues 5 por 5 nos da
25 no entonces la raíz cuadrada de 25 es
un 5 y aquí tenemos que multiplicar por
la raíz cuadrada de
que no se puede simplificar más entonces
listo la raíz de 50 es igual a 5 por la
raíz de 2 ahora es lo más natural que
ahorita tú quieras preguntarme pero como
le hiciste para escoger dividir a 50 en
25 por 2 ok por qué no escogiste la raíz
de 5 por 10 por ejemplo o no sé la raíz
de 1 por 50 y bueno creo que esas son
todas las formas de factorizar a 50 no
bueno el chiste es que escogí 25 por 2
porque yo sé que 25 es un cuadrado
perfecto y sabía que su raíz cuadrada es
igual a 5 y entonces que lo voy a poder
sacar de la raíz cuadrada y todo iba a
quedar muy bonito que el chiste aquí es
buscar cuáles de los factores de 50 son
cuadrados perfectos y pues con el tiempo
y la práctica uno aprende a reconocer
los cuadrados perfectos muy rápido
aunque luego vamos a ver métodos más
precisos para encontrarlos utilizando la
factorización en primos pero por el
momento igual y sería bueno escribir una
lista de cuáles son los cuadrados
perfectos para que los vayas
reconociendo por qué este método es
mucho más rápido y ágil
entonces para encontrar los cuadrados
perfectos pues lo que tenemos que hacer
es poner una lista de los primeros
números naturales por ejemplo 1 2
78 y ya no me caben más y elevarlos al
cuadrado ok
uno por uno es 12 por 24 3 por 39 4 por
4 16 5 por 5 25 6 por 6 36 7 por 7 49 y
8 por 8 64 entonces todos estos números
cuadrados perfectos son el cuadrado de
estos números de aquí de la izquierda
entonces siempre que vean alguno de
estos números que van a ver que después
los van a aparecer los números más
naturales siempre que vean alguno de
estos números ya saben que son cuadrados
perfectos y que su raíz es un número
entero y que entonces vamos a poder
usarlos para simplificar las raíces
cuadradas entonces pues vamos a hacer
más ejemplos
ahora queremos simplificar 7 por la raíz
cuadrada de 20 727 es igual a pues 3 por
9 no haber el 3 no es un cuadrado
perfecto pero el 9 si es un cuadrado
perfecto entonces si podemos simplificar
esta expresión entonces vamos a ponerle
7 por la raíz cuadrada de 3 por 9 que
como acabamos de ver esto es igual a 7
por la raíz es de 9 por la raíz y es de
309 es igual a tres por tres entonces
esto es igual a 7 por la raíz cuadrada
de 3 por 3 por la raíz cuadrada de 3
y entonces pues la raíz cuadrada de 3
por 3 es un 3
así es que aquí tenemos 7 por 3 por la
raíz de 3 y 7 por 3 es 21 y nos falta la
raíz de 3 aunque aquí siempre que
tengamos un número y una raíz a la
derecha aunque no pongamos el puntito de
que se están multiplicando se están
multiplicando entonces pues vamos a ver
otro ejercicio
entonces ahora vamos a simplificar 9 por
la raíz de 18
aunque ya verá 18 como lo podemos
factorizar pues obviamente está la
simple factorización de 118 pero 18 no
es un cuadrado perfecto también podemos
factorizar lo como 3 por 6 pero ni tres
ni seis son cuadrados perfectos entonces
realmente todavía no podemos simplificar
esto pero nos falta otra factorización
de 18 que es 2 por 9 el 2 no es un
cuadrado perfecto
pero el 9 si es un cuadrado perfecto
entonces vamos a escoger esta
factorización 9 x raíz de 18 es
exactamente igual a 9 por la raíz de 2
por 9
pero pues como hemos visto ya muchas
veces en este vídeo esto es igual a 9
por la raíz de 2 por la raíz de 9
y que dicen yo creo que la podemos
borrar esto no a ver entonces tenemos
aquí una raíz cuadrada de un cuadrado
perfecto que es 3 por 3 igual a 9
entonces esto es exactamente igual a 3
así es que esto es igual a 9 por la raíz
de dos por tres
entonces 9 por 3 27 raíz de 2
y listo 9 x raíz de 18 es igual a 27 por
raíz de 2 y 7 x raíz de 27 que es 21 por
raíz de 3 a ver ahora vamos a
simplificar 4 por la raíz cuadrada de 25
bueno pues esto es una pregunta un poco
truculento porque 25 ya es un cuadrado
perfecto entonces no tenemos que buscar
ninguna factorización 25 es igual a 5 al
cuadrado
entonces la raíz de 25 es igual a 5 así
es que esto es igual a 4 por 5
esta raíz es igual a 5 de este 5 y 4 por
5 es igual a 20 y entonces pues ahora
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo 3 por la raíz
cuadrada de 29 entonces 29 no es un
cuadrado perfecto vamos a ver qué
factores tiene a ver si encontramos un
cuadrado perfecto entre sus factores
pero a ver 29 sus factores son 1 por 29
y ya porque 29 es un número primo
entonces no lo podemos factorizar más
así es que pues no podemos simplificar
más su raíz cuadrada este número ya está
lo más simplificado que lo podemos tener
entonces vamos a borrar todo esto para
tener más espacio para hacer más
ejemplos
entonces ahora vamos a simplificar
por la raíz cuadrada de 320 entonces
bueno este número se ve muy grande no yo
creo que aquí nos vamos a tardar mucho
si tratamos de ver todos los factores de
320 entonces pues qué vamos a hacer qué
vamos a hacer
este 32 es igual a 2 por 16 y para
obtener este 0 simplemente tenemos que
multiplicar por 10 entonces podemos
escribirlo como 7 por la raíz cuadrada
de 320 es igual a 16 por 20 cierto
entonces hacemos lo que ya sabemos hacer
muy bien 7 por la raíz de 16 por la raíz
de 20 sabemos que la raíz de 16 es igual
a 4 porque 4 por 4 16 y entonces aquí
nos queda 7 por 4 20 8 por la tierra es
de 20 bueno no la verdad no porque 20
todavía tiene factores que son cuadrados
perfectos entonces esto lo podemos
simplificar todavía más si es que
20 es igual a 4 por 5 entonces esto es
igual a 28 por la raíz cuadrada de
cuatro por cinco pero 4 es un cuadrado
perfecto 4 es 2 al cuadrado entonces nos
vamos a ver muy ágiles en este paso y
vamos a sacar directamente el 2 de la
raíz cuadrada y nos queda 2 por 28 que
es igual a 56 por la raíz de 5 hayes y
esta igualdad no te parece clara ponle
pausa y hazlo a mano y vas a ver que te
sale todo perfecto entonces 7 por la
raíz de 320 es igual a 56 por la raíz de
5 aunque aquí en el fondo hicimos un
súper truco entre porque si hubiera sido
muy complicado escribir todos los
factores de 320 y encontrar cuál es el
cuadrado perfecto más grande entonces lo
que hicimos fue encontrar algo
un cuadrado perfecto que fue el primero
que nos saltó a la vista este 16 y
sacando ese cuadrado perfecto
simplificar esta expresión obteniendo
una que tiene una raíz cuadrada más
chica que es mucho más fácil de
simplificar hasta que obtengamos alguna
raíz que tenga un número primo adentro
bueno que de hecho no tiene a fuerzas
que será un número primo simplemente
tiene que ser algún número que no tenga
ningún factor que sea un cuadrado
perfecto aunque que no haya ningún
cuadrado perfecto que divida a ese
número entonces pues ya sabes si tienes
números muy grandes y quieres sacar su
raíz cuadrada puede decir simplificando
lo poco a poco bueno espero que sea muy
útil este vídeo y vas a ver que con el
tiempo y la práctica este tipo de
operaciones te van a parecer lo más
natural del mundo y van a ser muy útiles